hi everyone so today I'm going to tell
you about some new work where we're
characterizing chaotic dynamical systems
as intermittently forced linear systems
so we take chaotic dynamics and
represent them in a linear system
framework using modern Koopman operator
theory and we'll find that these systems
are intermittently forced corresponding
to rare events like lobe switching and
the attractor of the lorentz system or
bursting or other intermittent
phenomenon so it's a data driven
decomposition of chaos into a linear
system that is intermittently forced
this is work with my co-authors Bing
Brunton Josh Proctor Erika Kaiser and
Nathan cuts and before I jump in I just
want to say chaotic dynamical systems
are everywhere they describe lots of
fascinating phenomenon in the world
around us so the climate turbulent
fluids the stockmarket disease for a
spread the motion of planets are all
chaotic dynamical systems they're very
well studied and they fascinated people
for for a long time so we've said a long
time thinking about chaotic dynamical
systems interestingly chaos is not
random at all this is a kind of an early
misconception but chaotic systems are in
fact highly structured and there's lots
of patterns so this Lorentz example
attractor is a good example there's lots
of structure in this chaotic system and
we'll get into what what chaos means a
little bit more later so before jumping
into the the new analysis I just want to
give a recap so dynamical systems
history so the the original kind of
classic view of dynamical systems you
have X dot equals f of X X is the state
of your system this is some system of
coupled differential equations probably
nonlinear and you're interested in
understanding what initial conditions do
in this system so where do trajectories
go if I have all of the planets right
here right now where will they be
a hundred years in the future okay so
you want to be able to predict by
integrating the initial conditions
through these dynamics so that's what
we're doing over here and you can use
that to get a discrete-time update where
you go like what's my system at time now
and it tells you what your system is at
discrete measurements in the future this
is the classic geometric view all the
way back to point Caray and it's
concerned with how trajectories are
organized by things like saddle points
and periodic orbits and attractors so
geometric organization of trajectory is
in the dynamics the more modern kind of
Koopman operator perspective is that
instead of propagating the state of the
system through these nonlinear dynamics
it's possible to consider measurement
functions of the state so here we have G
is a function that measures my state it
could be sine of the first component or
the second component cubed or something
like that and so there's this infinite
dimensional space this hilbert space of
all possible measurements i could take
of my system
and so this Koopman operator k it always
exists and it's linear and it Maps my
measurement function G at time k TK to
the next instance of time TK plus 1 so
if I have my measurement G of my state
at time K and I hit it with the Koopman
operator it advances that measurement to
time k plus 1 so this always exists it's
linear but it's infinite dimensional so
we're trading finite dimensional
non-linear dynamics for infinite
dimensional linear dynamics in this
hilbert space of all possible
measurements now Koopman actually came
up with this quite a while ago in 1931
but it's only been recently kind of
developed and really applied in lots of
systems do the pioneering work message
and rally and collaborators where
they're really taking this data-driven
perspective okay so in lots of systems
of interest maybe a turbulent fluid
in a jet engine or the climate or the
stock market we might not even have a
good representation of the full dynamics
but we have tons of data and so building
up approximations of this Koopman
operator from data is a very promising
modern modern field of study and just to
remind you these systems are hard to
work with
they're nonlinear they might not even be
very easy to solve and integrates linear
systems if I can get this Koopman linear
representation I can do all kinds of
things that are standard in linear
linear analysis I can do future state
predictions optimal estimation optimal
control basically it just reduces this
to a linear algebra problem which is
great and the perspective we've been
taking in recent work is that to get a
good approximation of the Koopman
operator a finite dimensional
approximation you need Koopman invariant
measurement space so this is a subspace
of your infinite dimensional hilbert
space of possible measurements where if
I if I took a measurement of my system
in the subspace and I hit it with
Koopman I would say in the subspace okay
if I have that kind of an invariant
measurement subspace if I restrict my
Koopman operator to that that subspace I
get a finite dimensional linear operator
a matrix K and I get a linear dynamical
system that propagates those eigen kind
of those those measurements those good
measurements forward in time so I can do
a linear optimal control optimal
estimation future state prediction the
trick here and the problem is that
finding those invariant measurement
subspaces might be exceedingly difficult
those invariant subspaces are related to
eigenfunctions of the Koopman operator
and these might be very difficult to
find hard to represent and they carry as
much information as the full solution of
the dynamics in some cases okay so
finding good invariant measurement
subspaces is critical because there's so
much powerful theory and analysis that
you can do once you have a linear
representation so I'm going to tell you
about this this new analysis that we
have
and I'm going to demonstrate it on the
lorentz system because this is really a
good toy problem that illustrates chaos
it's very well studied so here I took an
initial cube of trajectories and I'm
integrating them through you see that
very rapidly these trajectories stretch
and kind of mix on the attractor and so
this is kind of a graphical illustration
of the sensitive dependence of the
lorentz system to the initial conditions
so that little cube of red initial
conditions was all pretty close but
after a short amount of time they get
stretched and folded kind of like taffy
and spread on to this this attractor
okay so this is the prototypical example
of chaos that we're going to analyze and
what we're going to do is develop this
new view of Koopman to get invariant
measurement spaces that we're calling
the Hankel alternative view of Koopman
or havoc analysis okay and we're going
to demonstrate it on the Ritz so we take
the low-rent system and the first
assumption is that maybe we don't have
access to all the measurements of our
chaotic system maybe we can just measure
a time series of X so this is what the
time series of X looks like it you know
when it's up here it's on one lobe of
the attractor then it's on the other
lobe and it switches and the switching
is maybe hard to predict so we measure a
time series of one variable X we build a
Hankel matrix this H matrix here by
taking the time series and then time
shifted copies so T one time one to time
P time two to P plus one 3 to P plus two
and so on I stack those as rows of my
Hankel matrix and then I take the
singular value decomposition of this
Hankel matrix and I get eigen time delay
coordinates I get these eigen eigen time
series that are ordered from most
important to least important and their
ability to express this data okay so I
get these eigen time series and the
columns of U and the columns of V and
those are the time series that are most
self-similar
to the time series that we use to train
this model okay this idea of building a
Hankel matrix and taking the singular
value decomposition is not new it's used
in the eigen system realization
algorithm it's used in the singular
spectrum analysis and climate there's
recent extensions of SSA by Jian aqus
and Maite the nonlinear laplacian
spectral analysis which is a really neat
modern data driven kind of view of these
Hankel matrices but the upshot is once I
have this data and I build a Hankel
matrix and I take my singular value
decomposition I get a good measurement
system a good set of delay coordinates
where if I plot my trajectory in these
new delay coordinates this delay
embedding gives me an attractor which is
Diffie amorphic to my original attractor
okay and again this is not new this goes
all the way back to talk ins who is
studying this in the context of
turbulence and many many people many
more than in this list here have have
analyzed time delay embeddings for
nonlinear systems and so the what I'm
actually plotting here the columns of V
are time histories of the first eigen
time series the second the third the
fourth and so on and I'm plotting those
time histories of the first three eigen
time series so this is V 1 V 2 V 3
coordinate system and this is my data in
that coordinate system so I'm literally
just plotting the first three columns of
V and what's really neat is that there's
a connection between this data driven
the singular value decomposition of the
Hankel matrix and the Koopman operator
so I can take my Hankel matrix and
instead of writing at X at time 1 X at
time 2 times 3 times 4 and so on I can
instead write it in terms of iterates of
the Koopman operator okay so remember
Koopman acts on measurements of the
state and this is just a measurement of
the X component of the state so I can
take X at time 1 if I hit it with
Koopman I get X at time 2 so this is X
at time 2 if I hit it with Koopman again
I get X at time 3 and so on and so forth
so I basically get this this series of
increasing powers of the Koopman
operator applied to X at time one this
is another view of the Hankel matrix and
what's really neat is that when we take
the singular value decomposition of this
Hankel matrix we find that even though
this thing has lots and lots of columns
in this example for the Henkel matrix
maybe I have 10,000 columns I get low
rank structure that emerges from the
singular value decomposition and I might
find for example that the first 15
columns of U of this U matrix and the
the singular value decomposition the
first 15 columns are adequate for
describing all of the columns of H so
every column of H up to numerical
precision is linearly dependent on the
first 15 columns of U very cool and what
this means is that essentially the
second column of this Hankel matrix is
just Koopman acting on the first column
the third column is Koopman acting on
the second and so on and so forth i act
on all these columns by Koopman and i
get the next column and what that's
telling me is that these 15 leading
columns of U these leading eigen time
delays are invariant to the Koopman
operator because if I at least four data
on the attractor that's not true for all
data but four data on the attractor if I
have one column and I hit it with
Koopman I'm still going to be in the
span of U so this is a Koopman invariant
measurement system given by eigen time
delays of the Hinkel matrix and it's
data driven very very cool ok and again
this is where the Hankel and the Koopman
in the havok model come come from so the
fact that we have this connection with
the Koopman operator we can represent
the Hankel matrix in terms of the
Koopman operator we get this data-driven
basis for making the columns linearly
dependent and giving us an invariant
subspace this all motivates building a
regression model on these time delay
coordinates because we probably have a
linear system underneath in the right
coordinate system that's what Koopman
tells us
and this is related to the dynamic mode
decomposition and the sparse
identification of nonlinear dynamics
which are regression methods that take
data and give you models except here
we're doing this linear regression fit
on these eigen time delay coordinates
from the SVD of the Hankel matrix and so
what we find is that right off the bat
we can build this linear regression
model it's super simple in that lab
basically just the backslash of the
pseudo inverse so we build this linear
regression model that best maps that the
best describes these columns of V and
what we find is that the first R minus
one delay coordinates are very well
approximated by a linear model this
linear part of this linear model up here
the last time delay coordinate in this
case the fifteenth time delay coordinate
does not have a very good fit the V dot
equals equation for the fifteenth time
delay coordinate is not very good even
if I include nonlinear terms it's not
great so what we decided was let's act
like this last time delay coordinate
let's not try to model it let's say it's
an external forcing we can measure it by
you know if I'm measuring a streaming
set of data I can measure what my V R
coefficient is let's have that enter as
a forcing term to this linear model so I
have a linear model kind of V dot equals
AV plus B times this forcing term okay
and here in red I'm showing a little
snippet of that V are forcing term for
this data and you see that it's mostly
quiescent but every once in a while it
bursts it turns on and then it goes off
again so if you run that linear sorry
that intermittent forcing into this
linear model what you get out is a
prediction of what the dynamics of the
system are doing that's plotted here in
blue linear dynamics and the blue is our
prediction based on this regression
model plot it on top of the white which
is actually the data so you get a very
good linear model prediction if you give
it the right intermittent forcing and so
if you run this
or enough data you can build a
reconstruction that looks very similar
to this embedded system except our blue
manifold is really coming from linear
Koopman dynamics with this special
intermittent forcing signature okay and
what's interesting is you actually see
that this intermittent forcing this
intermittent forcing signal if you look
at its probability distribution in the
very lower right it's non normal so the
the Gaussian is the white dashed line
it's very non normal it's got these long
tails corresponding to rare event
extreme forcing so these when these red
signals get really big that's rare and
it's non Gaussian and it happens to
correspond to when the lorentz system is
about to switch to the other lobe of the
attractor okay so whenever this red
signal gets big my system switches to
another lobe which is very cool so we're
gonna look at that again in a minutes
and this is similar to ideas of
intermittent forcing and extremer events
found in in work by saps esand mighta
and and others looking at things like
climate and ocean extreme ocean waves
and things like that so so there's some
really neat work out there looking at
intermittent forcing and we're taking
and looking at this intermittent forcing
for this Koopman linear system okay so
you can take all the pieces of that
havoc analysis on Lorentz you have a
system you measure some aspect of the
system you build time delay coordinates
and get an embedded attractor you can
then build a linear model with a forced
linear model you get a good and
reconstructed attractor when you do that
and you have some forcing statistics so
we have gone through and actually
applied this havoc analysis to lots of
systems from you know classical chaotic
system like Lorentz and Rossler to kind
of mechanical systems like the double
pendulum to more real-world relevant
systems like we have time series data
for a model of the Earth's magnetic
field switching so this happens every
once in a while
ECG electrocardiogram data for
heartbeats
EEG electroencephalogram for a patient
that's asleep and there
their brain is being measured down to
measles outbreaks so this is real
historic measles data from New York City
so you can apply this havoc analysis to
all of these systems and you get very
interesting predictions and you can
download all of the code and look at any
of these examples more more of yourself
but we're gonna dive a little bit more
until our rent system here because what
I really want to show you is that these
havoc models are actually predictive
their predictive of lobe switching so
here I'm plotting the v1 this is the
leading delay coordinate in time VR is
the forcing term this is like the
fifteenth eye ghen time delay
coordinates and I choose 15 using the
optimal hard threshold of GABA Shin
Donahoe for the SVD and then in the
bottom plot this is the forcing squared
so that it kind of stands out a little
more and it's positive and what you find
is that most of the time the forcing is
inactive it's small and that actually
means the system is really well
described by a Koopman linear system so
all of these white regions mean the
system is essentially linear there's not
really any forcing happening and then
every once in a while you get these
bursts these big bursts of activity in
the forcing that we color code in red so
anytime this is larger than some
threshold we color code at red and then
we code our trajectory when that forcing
is active and what you find is that when
the forcing is active it actually
proceeds a lobe switching by by one
whole period by one whole revolution of
the lobe so you get this great
prediction when this red signal comes on
that the lobe is about to switch which
is great and it's not perfect we don't
capture every single one of them but
it's pretty good it's pretty predictive
okay and you can take those red regions
and actually color code the embedded
attractor by whether or not the forcing
is active that's red or whether or not
the forcing is inactive in white and so
fascinating the white region here is
really very well described by this
Koopman linear system without forcing
because remember forcing is small and
these red regions correspond to
enforcing is large when forcing is act
so we get this nice linear model in
white that actually characterizes the
inter regions the interior regions of
both lobes which is fascinating and then
these coherent regions in red which tell
us when we're about to switch and so I
like this plot because it's kind of the
skeleton of this behavior so let's say
we start this is real data from Lorentz
color coded by the forcing so let's say
we start the trajectory at Point a we do
four inner revolutions on the right lobe
and the system is linear essentially
kind of Koopman linear and then at point
B are forcing spikes and this is
something you can measure you're
measuring your time history or
convolving with the columns of U from
the SVD and you're measuring this
forcing signature when the forcing gets
large enough that's at point B we know
that the system is about to switch and
we have an entire other extra revolution
before the system actually switches so
we get this whole prediction window
where we know the system is about to
switch it does in fact switch over to
Point C the forcing becomes small again
which tells us hey we're gonna be here
for a while and then we are in this
Koopman linear system for three more
revolutions until point B when the
forcing goes up again and we know that
we're about to switch another time so
very cool very predictive and easily
interpretable and measurable okay
so again we've applied this to lots more
systems we encourage you to download all
of the code here you can try all the
examples yourself again this is another
piece in this puzzle we want to go from
data to dynamical systems we have to
measure the right things and now we're
learning from like talking's embedding
theory and you know observability theory
what to measure what are good
measurements we need good
representations where the dynamics
become simple this is where Koopman
comes in and time delay coordinates so
good time delay coordinates give us a
good representation of our dynamics that
are essentially linear or at least in
large portions of phase space and then
regression is somehow the easy part we
have lots of powerful tools for machine
learning to get models once we have good
representations and good measurements
and lots of data okay thank you very
much there will be another short video
showing kind of more examples and more
details about this method thank you